remember they're just jokes he's back
ricky gervais took the stage at the
Beverly Hilton in Beverly Hills on
Sunday kicking off the 2020 Golden
Globes with a bang Kevin Hart was fired
from the Oscars because of some
offensive tweets hello
it was the 58 year olds fifth time
hosting the show and his opening
monologue was chock-full of shade it's
the last time okay
now we're breaking down the five biggest
zingers starting with this I came here
in a limo tonight and the license plate
was made by Felicity Huffman it's a it's
her daughter I feel sorry for okay that
must be the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to her and her dad
was in wild hogs yep he went there
taking aim at William H Macy and his
wife Felicity who served eleven days in
prison for her role in the college
admissions scandal next up Ricky took a
jab at Leo's love life once upon a time
in Hollywood nearly three hours long
Leonardo DiCaprio attended the premiere
and by the end his date was too old for
him
Ricky also weighed in on the recent
box-office failure of cats the world got
to see James Corden as a fat [ __ ]
it was also in the movie cats but no one
saw that things took a crude turn when
he talked about James's co-star Judi
Dench who previously defended the film
saying it was the role she was born to
play because she loves nothing better
than clunking herself down on the carpet
lifting a leg and licking her and last
but not least Riki pokes fun at Irishmen
star Joe Pesci comparing him to one
adorable tiny Star Wars character baby
Yoda Oh Gus that's Joe Pesci sorry Ricky
announced in November that it would be
his last time hosting the Golden Globes
saying in a press release quote once
again they've made me an offer I can't
refuse but this is the very last time
I'm doing this which could make for a
fun evening I think is the first first
time because it was a you know a big
opportunity it was very flattering of
you know a global audience of quarter of
a billion people that's for a comedian
that's irresistible and they said I
could say what I wanted and they kept to
that which was great then they invited
me that I thought I will do it again
because I think I can do a better job
then I did it a third time
because after the second everyone said
I'd never be invited back so but like
the idea of that I did it I did it as a
fourth time because I suppose it's just
fun but this is the last time there's a
limit
[Music]